Henri Leclerc l'enfance décide écrivait
Jean-Paul Sartre dans les mots qu'a donc
décidé votre enfance
je crois que mon enfant
qui a été en partie faite pendant la
guerre
m'a quand même assez ouvert sur la
complexité du monde d'abord et les
problèmes qui étaient posés et puis
s'assure je crois que j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir des parents assez exceptionnel
dont ma mère était pieuse est religieuse
mon père était complètement diagnostique
et il s'entendait très bien et c'est
quelque chose qui crée à mon avis pour
la vie une nature tolérante et bon je
pense que cette éducation familiale est
pour beaucoup l'ont même dans ce que je
suis devenu mais d'où vous vient cet
instinct de défense
d'une envie d'une envie et ça je crois
que je l'ai eu très tôt c'est-à-dire que
je lorsque je vois quelqu'un qui est qui
est accablé j'ai envie de le défendre
c'est tout c'est une disposition mentale
c'est une disposition mentale mais ça
vient aussi de l'horreur de l'épuration
une forme de dégoût pour cette justice
dévoyée cette atmosphère de lingembre
mais j'avais été très frappé j'ai été
très frappé hier en fait générateur
c'est mon père était
écouté Radio Londres tous les soirs il
avait des contacts etc mais il était
pour lui Vichy c'était un bominable et
j'ai un souvenir très frappant du jour
où mon père est rentré très en colère
parce que on avait condamné là-bas la
mort on l'avait exécuté dans des
conditions absolument pas minables on
n'avait pas jugé en fait cet état un
alibi bon et
il était très en colère alors que depuis
quatre ans j'entendais dire que la valve
était un type abominable et ça c'est
quelque chose qui m'a donné après
quelques années après à lire le livre
calberno l'avocat de Laval avait été
écrit ça m'a secoué et après il se
trouve que dès que j'ai été avocat il
n'y a pas de hasard en fait j'ai été le
collaborateur d'anderno vous avez
commencé auprès des berneaux alors vous
êtes Henri Leclerc l'un des derniers
totem du droit pénal votre nom est
associé à la plupart des grandes
affaires criminales de ces 40 dernières
années la liste de vos faits d'armes
donne le tournis on ne compte plus les
ténors du barreau qui vous cite en
exemple ni l'évocation que vous avez
inspiré alors à 88 ans et du haut de vos
65 ans d'exercices seriez-vous dire
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui fait un grand
avocat
je crois que ce qui fait un grand avocat
c'est son d'abord son envie de défendre
premier point et deuxièmement
ça ça
j'allais dire ça sincérité c'est à dire
cette propension qu'il a à parler et à
parler aux gens comme
plaider comme comme on parle à quelqu'un
pour le convaincre quand on a quelqu'un
qu'on aime bien un proche et qu'on a une
discussion avec lui cette propension à
croire à ce qu'on dit et à convaincre
justement on a souvent entendu parler de
vous en ces termes Leclerc ne plaît pas
il parle il parle au juge au juré à son
adversaire comme on parlerait à un ami
en lui confiant ses certitudes c'est
doutes ces interrogations qui vous a
appris à murmurer à l'oreille des juré à
parler la langue qu'il a l'heure et non
pas celle de du code de procédure pénal
d'abord il faut pour ça il faut d'abord
bien connaître le code de procédure
pénale c'est-à-dire qu'il faut être très
solide sur les bases juridiques car
d'abord savoir qu'on plaide aux assises
mais complet aussi beaucoup en
correctionnel ou d'autres affaires même
parfois les affaires civiles
tout ça tout ça c'est c'est
quelque chose que j'ai est-ce que c'est
mon patron qui m'a appris ça Alberto
était un homme très simple mais c'était
un très bon orateur aussi mais enfin
d'une dénoquence assez simple il m'a
jamais rien appris mais je l'ai vu
travailler pendant des années vous vous
méfiez de l'éloquence et des grandes
plaidoiries je méfie les locquence je
méfie de l'éloquence parce que j'ai la
première affaire que j'ai plaidé et
cette affaire d'un yougoslave qui buvait
les bouteilles de lait j'étais très
content de cette affaire je trouvais que
c'était très intéressant
immigré qui dans Paris avait faim et qui
n'avait d'autres solutions que de boire
une gorgée de lait dans les bouteilles
qui étaient à l'époque devant les
magasins et qui avait été pris sur le
fait et je vais faire plaidoirie dont
j'étais content d'ailleurs dont le
président m'a félicité mais il apprécie
moi et là ce jour-là j'ai compris que il
ne fallait pas plaider pour la beauté
des mots les mon patron avait une
formule extraordinaire il disait
méfiez-vous des viol leur son est beau
mais leur ventre est creux et le le la
belle plaidoirie je suis sensible aussi
mais elle n'est pas forcément
convaincante elle n'est pas forcément
convaincante parce que ce qui est
convaincant c'est ce qui vient de
l'intérieur et les mots sont donnés par
la suite elle peut être belle la
plaidoirie sincère mais il est
nécessaire d'abord qu'elle soit sincère
alors vous plaidez un peu comment
respire c'est presque une seconde nature
en tout cas votre marque de fabrique il
semblerait aussi que comme chez les
acteurs le placement de la voix soit
aussi décisif et il faut qu'il sonne un
peu comme un saxo absolument je crois
que quand on veut parler quand on veut
convaincre des gens dans une audience
publique
il faut que la voix soit entendue et je
dirais que il y a je parlais il y a un
instant de la sincérité qui est très
importante mais il y a aussi le son de
la voix qui est séduisant il faut que le
on entend de sa voix être entendu c'est
un élément que je crois très important
être entendu comme peuvent l'être les
acteurs qu'est-il de commun entre un
acteur et un avocat un cercle acteur il
dit un texte qui n'est pas le sien et
que l'avocat dit un texte qui est le
sien ça c'est la première chose ça c'est
la différence mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a
de commun secret je pense que comme il y
a des acteurs différents il y a des
avocats différents quand on entend
d'entrer des artistes Louis Jouvet
donnait des conseils à Bernard Blier à
ceux qui étaient ses élèves à l'époque
aurait très bien il leur explique
imprégner le texte et à ce moment-là le
sentiment va vous venir en fait il y a
dans l'histoire célèbre dialogue de
Diderot qui s'appelle le paradoxe sur
lequel comédien et dans lequel Diderot
essaie de comparer les les comédiens qui
sont froids et qui avec leur
intelligence restitue la vérité du texte
et ceux qui imprègnent complètement le
personnage qu'il joue et bon alors je
crois que chez les avocats c'est un peu
pareil c'est à dire que vous avez des
avocats moi j'ai entendu plaider de très
grands avocats un homme comme Maurice
garçon par exemple conservait un froid
et son émotion était un peu feintes
quand elle avait lieu c'était
l'intelligence du texte et puis vous
avez des avocats qui sont complètement
imprégnés par ce qu'ils disent et qui
sont des personnages présents vivants
alors
ce qui ce qu'il rapproche de du comédien
ben c'est ce paradoxe c'est ce fait
qu'il y a plusieurs types d'avocats et
vous de quel type d'avocat qui a besoin
de de d'être profondément imprégné de ce
qu'il dit c'est évident votre confrère
pierre Haïk prétend que vous êtes
beaucoup plus qu'un avocat est-ce que
vous pensez que vous vous définiriez par
exemple comme un militant je suis un peu
que c'est-à-dire que je il faut bien
voir que je suis un militant en même
temps c'est à dire que je n'ai jamais
été seulement avocat j'ai été avocat et
militant
je me suis engagé politiquement d'abord
politiquement directement dans la
politique aux côtés de Michel Rocard
dans un parti qui s'appelait le PSU il y
a très longtemps j'étais très proche de
lui puis j'ai quitté complètement la
politique du moins la politique
politicienne pour m'engager la Ligue des
droits de l'homme dont j'ai été
président et pour défendre les droits de
l'homme en France et dans le monde bien
sûr vous êtes l'un des rares sinon le
seul ténor à avoir fixé les honoraires
de vos consultations sur le prix d'une
consultation médicale
cette période de ma vie oui c'est
lorsque nous avons fait une expérience
celui d'un cabinet social qui était à la
fois une coopérative en quelque sorte ou
tous les avocats étaient à égalité et
partagés les revenus et et nous avions
simplement fait une boutique sur la
route et pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
dérive pour que ça ne soit pas mal
compris nous étions sur la rue ouvert
etc et le principe qu'on avait fixé
c'est qu'on ferait quand même payer les
gens qui viendraient prendre une
consultation et nous avions envisagé le
prix de la consultation médicale c'est
une expérience qui a duré 20 ans quand
même est-ce que vous regrettez cette
époque est-ce que vous avez la nostalgie
de cette époque je n'ai pas la nostalgie
c'est un combat qui a été mené pendant
20 ans et puis qui a plus ou moins
échoué c'est-à-dire que
qui a réussi vingt ans c'est pas mal et
puis à la fin on s'est trouvé avec des
difficultés vous savez les gens changent
les bons mais mais je ne regrette pas
cette expérience
logique de cette
on est toujours nostalgique de ce qu'on
fait quand on a moins de 40 ans et
ensuite c'est la première nostalgie
c'est-à-dire la nostalgie de la jeunesse
ou la seconde jeunesse je dirais mais
c'est aussi la la l'envie d'avoir tenté
quelque chose pour pour changer un peu
le la justice en partant de ce qui était
les avocats je l'ai tenté je vais en
partir réussie il y a beaucoup de jeunes
avocats qui aujourd'hui sont sur ce
genre de comportement vous êtes arrivés
de chanter pour les audiences écoutez ça
ça n'empêche pas Nicolas que la Commune
n'est pas morte tout ça n'empêche pas
Nicolas que la communauté
[Musique]
c'était la fin de votre plaidoirie pour
la famille du militant pierre au Verney
vous étiez nombreux à fredonner en salle
d'audience ou à donner de la voix pour
un ténor c'est le service minimum non
c'est il faut que ça vienne c'est-à-dire
que c'est pas ce n'est pas une méthode
habituelle mais je me souviens très bien
de cette affaire qui était très
émouvante par certains côtés et c'est
vrai qu'à la fin quand j'évoquais ce qui
avait été le combat échoué de tous ces
de tous ces gens qui avec Pierre Obernai
avait voulu faire la révolution je
pensais que on avait
c'est voyez c'est ça c'est le propre de
la plaidoirie improvisée c'est à dire
que la pensée tire un peu la parole et
je pensais pierre renard je l'évoquais
en fin de plaidoirie qu'on avait enterré
au cimetière du père de chaise au mur de
fédérer là où était les derniers Morts
de la commune et brusquement j'ai pensé
à cette chanson qui évoquait
effectivement la commune avec la Commune
n'est pas morte et j'ai terminé en
fredonnant cette chanson tout ça
n'empêche pas Nicolas que la Commune
n'est pas morte et j'ai terminé par les
premiers couplet du Temps des Cerises
bon alors est-ce que c'était un artifice
j'en sais rien mais c'est quelque chose
que j'avais envie de faire je parlais au
juré je voyais le regard ils étaient
émus et j'ai voulu en quelque sorte
restitué ce qu'avait été un homme comme
au Vernet qui était un militaire
révolutionnaire et et effectivement
vous improvisiez tout était écrit
puis après j'avais surtout un classement
des pièces dont je pourrais avoir besoin
et
à la fin même ces pièces je les citais
de mémoire et si vous voulez le fait de
lire une pièce c'était simplement pour
pour bien montrer que c'était vrai bon
et après je m'apercevrai que quand je
disais il y a cette pièce on croyait et
donc je là je me suis mis de plus en
plus à improviser totalement vous
improvisiez mais vous aviez un ange
parlez moi de cet ange qui vous a
soufflé tout au long de vos 65 ans de
plaidoirie vos mots vous savez je vous
le raconte c'est quand j'étais étudiant
en jeu je menais des combats politico
syndicaux et j'avais pour adversaire
principal la Faculté de Droit Jean-Marie
Le Pen et je me souviens très bien que
alors que j'avais 18 ans on m'avait
demandé de faire un discours offensif et
je me suis rendu compte j'avais préparé
et je me suis rendu compte que
brusquement il y a quelque chose qui se
passait c'est-à-dire que les mots entrés
dans penser j'avançais et que je je
parlais à des gens et que je bandais
très bien compte que s'ils avaient une
émotion fallait pousser cette émotion
s'ils avaient envie de rire il fallait
pousser ce rire et et c'est là que j'ai
dit c'est un ange qui arrive quand je
plaide pour que ça vienne de l'intérieur
faut-il être convaincu de l'innocence de
son client pour bien le défendre je
crois qu'il faut en mettre convaincu
alors est-ce que est-ce que on est
vraiment
alors je crois qu'on l'est vraiment je
sais qu'un jour on me le racontait une
de mes anciens collaborateurs il paraît
que je suis rentré à mon cabinet furieux
parce qu'un client qui avait été
poursuit pour des meurtres avaient été
condamné à 10 ans et que je trouvais que
c'était scandaleux qu'il était innocent
etc alors mais mes associés mon Dieu
coûte on connaît le dossier quand même
comment tu as pu croire vraiment que ce
type est 1900 et j'ai dit s'il y a un
moment où je l'ai cru c'est quand j'ai
plaidé c'est-à-dire que il y a quelque
chose qui incarne et à ce moment-là les
choses s'organisent vous savez le roi
gourmandisait que c'est cette il parlait
de cette faculté déconcertante qu'on les
faits de s'aligner dans le bon ordre
pourvu qu'on les éclaire d'un seul côté
à la fois et quand on a commencé à
éclairer les faits d'une certaine façon
il s'organisent ils s'organise et il y a
une espèce de conviction qui vient
est-ce que cette conviction qui permet
cette sincérité car
quand on ne croit pas l'innocence quand
on y croit vraiment pas il faut il faut
le dire il faut trouver le moyen pour
plaider autrement il faut faut
convaincre son client il faut se retirer
au besoin au fond le Graal pour un
avocat c'est de réussir à faire exister
l'accusé en dehors de ce qu'il a fait
c'est-à-dire que le tiret vers le haut
à bien entendu bien entendu il faut
tirer vers le haut la personne qu'on
défend ça c'est absolument indispensable
et là il faut effectivement se le cœur
même de la défense et je dis parmi les
le mot d'ordre de la République c'est le
mot fraternité et
il est évident que on défend quelqu'un
il faut faire apparaître comme un être
humain comme un être humain comme les
autres et là véritablement c'est rare
que je me sois trouvé en difficulté
totale mais y a-t-il des défenses
impossibles parce que vous dites que le
mal absolu n'existe pas vous n'avez
jamais rencontré
le mal absolu
j'ai rencontré des cas très difficile
mais je me suis souvent aperçu que dans
la parole dans le dialogue qu'on pouvait
avoir avec une personne on s'apercevait
qu'il était à notre alors bien sûr les
chemins de la conséquences les les
raisons la passion enfin tout ce qui
peut amener les actes violents tout cela
on le découvre au fur et à mesure et moi
je crois que
au fond il faut avoir envie de défendre
quelqu'un
un individu dans un procès il est
tellement isolé tellement accablé il y a
tellement de choses que on a moi j'ai
envie j'ai envie de dire non c'est pas
tout à fait aussi simple par exemple
défendre un violent d'enfants c'est très
difficile c'est très difficile parce que
lorsque j'en ai défendu j'en ai pas
c'est pas pas beaucoup mais
le problème c'est que en général celui
qui est accusé ni l'effet bon donc à ce
moment-là on se trouve en face d'une
situation mais après tout c'est pas
parce que l'enfant l'accuse qu'il est
coupable mais en même temps à ce
moment-là l'enfant devient presque un
ennemi et donc le procès est très
difficile alors comme c'est un violeur
d'enfant qui avoue c'est pas facile non
plus parce que les gens disent et en
plus ils s'en ventes quoi en gros donc
c'est une des défenses les plus
difficiles qui soient Henri Leclerc on
plaide toujours pour le droit jamais
pour la morale même si un verdict ou un
non-lieu est moralement injuste
le droit je me refuse de trouver une
distinction entre le droit et la morale
voilà je je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
droit qui ne soit pas moral mais le
il était évident qu'il peut y avoir des
décisions qui sont injustes et des
décisions de condamnation et même
peut-être des décisions d'équipement
parce que pour certains avocats qu'un
client soit une notion en coupable ce
n'est pas la question ce qui prime c'est
le respect du droit et non la recherche
de la vérité c'est en particulier le ce
que développait beaucoup Thierry Lévy
c'est-à-dire ce qui compte c'est le
droit c'est le procédure etc donc pas la
morale non pas la morale moi
personnellement je m'en refuse à
distinguer vraiment les deux et je crois
que ce qui est juste ce qui est juste ce
n'est pas seulement de respect du droit
quand vous voyez que les peines
des peines considérables que une
personne peut être condamnée à la fois à
la perpétuité et avant c'était même la
peine de mort ou à deux ans de prison
vous rendez bien compte qu'il y a un
espace considérable où est la part du
juste la part du juste est-ce que c'est
la part du droit c'est la proportion
mais comment comment on évalue la
proportion d'une peine par rapport en
fait tout ça est très compliqué alors
justement diriez-vous que la justice des
hommes fabriquent parfois une iniquité
plus grande que celle qu'elle entend
réparer
je crois effectivement que la justice
des hommes peut les rappeler et que
c'est ce qui existe depuis le pire étant
bien entendu que la justice condamne en
innocent ça c'est quand même et et
condamné un innocence c'est c'est
faire une entorse au principe
normalement la team conviction devrait
protéger c'est-à-dire que la conscience
la raison qui sont au cœur de l'intime
conviction devrait protéger le fait
condamner à Nissan et mais en fait ça
c'est pas vrai la justice est une
institution qui a des dérapages et nous
sommes là pour essayer d'éviter au
maximum que ça se passe et juste arrivé
maintenant de plaider ventes face
autrement dit contre l'opinion publique
aux côtés de Richard roman ou de DSK
mais aussi du côté des parties civils
dans la faire remar Haddad
de la même manière quand on est du côté
de l'accusé et du côté de la victime
quand on plaide pour l'accusé il suffit
de le doute du doute il suffit du doute
quand on plaide pour la victime on a une
espèce d'obligation morale de la
conviction vous restez convaincu de la
culpabilité de Marada oui
j'ai dit pourquoi j'en suis convaincu
mais si un jour on me démontre que j'ai
fait une erreur je le regretterai vous
avez littéralement failli être lynché
quand vous défendiez Richard roman
regardez ces images cette reconstitution
à la mode du Caire restera l'un des
souvenirs les plus cuisants de votre
carrière
désespoir ratisés par la vue de ce
mannequin censé représenter leur enfant
les deux inculpés étant absent la
famille va violemment s'acharner
maintenant sur l'autre avocat de la
défense on avait jamais vu ça
c'est un souvenir
c'est un souvenir fort
c'est un souvenir fort mais bon c'est
pas c'est pas j'ai pas été lâché à mort
j'ai pris quelques coups j'ai saignais
mais enfin c'est tout mais c'est vrai
que c'est un souvenir fort parce que
c'est un souvenir qui pose véritablement
le problème de la responsabilité et de
la défense et bien entendu ce n'est pas
ça qui m'a retenu complet et je rappelle
que Richard roman était acquitté après
absolument il a été quitté pas seulement
par un espèce d'accident de procédure
comme ça arrive mais je dirais que
l'ensemble de ceux qui assistaient au
procès étaient convaincu son innocence
alors aujourd'hui le lynchage s'est
déplacé sur les réseaux sociaux les
structures mentales ont changé ce qui
était acceptable hier nous les plus
aujourd'hui qu'il s'agisse du sexisme
ordinaire ou des violences sexuelles
plus encore après mis tout font-ils sont
réjouir ou s'inquiéter du point de vue
stricto sensu du droit on peut pas on ne
peut pas sacrifier le droit c'est à dire
que il y a nous sommes en phase d'un
problème nous sommes en phase d'un
problème c'est qu'il existe un jugement
de l'opinion publique et ce jugement de
l'opinion publique il démarre avec des
éléments qui ne sont pas les preuves
bien sûr il y a des accusations mais
tout accusation n'est pas une preuve en
elle-même certes dans la plupart des cas
ces accusations sont réelles mais elles
ne sont pas forcément des preuves or
cette espèce de de certitude de
l'opinion publique qui condamne un homme
surtout pour les faits comme ça au
pylori c'est-à-dire qu'il est il est
plus il devient hors circuit alors qu'il
n'a pas été jugé c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement pénible et à mon avis qui
pose un véritable problème car seul la
justice peut avoir des éléments
suffisants contradictoires le débat oral
l'analyse complète des faits
l'accusation la défense pour
un bilan et dire effectivement
quelle est la vérité publique pourtant
de plus en plus de personnalités
préfèrent témoigner par écrit ou par
voie de presse plutôt que de porter
plainte comprenez-vous qu'Adèle à NL
Vanessa springora ou encore Camille
kuchner pour le citer qu'elle et choisit
cette voie plutôt de pousser la porte
d'un commissariat mais je le comprends
très bien je comprends très bien
qu'effectivement ce soit plus efficace
et que ce dont ont envie la plupart des
victimes ou des proches des victimes qui
témoignent c'est c'est que le fait soit
reconnu c'est qu'il soit reconnu comme
victime et la voie médiatique est plus
rapide que la voie judiciaire la voie
judiciaire a un gros défaut c'est
qu'elle démarre dans le secret en
principe un secret qui est d'ailleurs en
permanence violée il y a des fuites qui
se passent un certain nombre de choses
c'est vrai et de quoi est-ce le symptôme
vous ne pensez pas au fond c'est aussi
le symptôme d'une justice qui est de
plus en plus discrédité c'est le signe
que la justice n'est pas le seul élément
qui disent le juste l'opinion publique
dit d'une certaine façon le juste mais
l'opinion publique n'a pas de garantie
elle n'a pas les garanties du droit et
donc c'est vrai qu'on se trouve
actuellement dans une situation
particulièrement difficile parce que la
transformation du monde sur le sujet des
violences faites aux femmes sur le sujet
des viols et est à progrès considérable
ça c'est vrai mais en même temps ce
progrès affaiblit l'institution
judiciaire et peut détruire des hommes
de façon injuste Henri Leclerc vous avez
raccroché la robe à 86 ans après avoir
plaidé une dernière fois aux assises en
novembre 2020 dans le procès de Julien C
accusé d'avoir voulu immoler sa petite
amie une plaidoirie historique tous vos
pères sont venus y assister un procès
qui s'est soldé néanmoins par une
condamnation à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle ce verdict nous a blessé vous
le trouvez injuste
oui profondément je vis avec ça et je
suis personnellement j'ai j'ai été
convaincu qu'il y avait dans cette
affaire un doute considérable un doute
tel que je j'ai c'est vrai que j'ai
terminé par un échec et il est
douloureux alors vous avez enfin il est
surtout douloureux par mon client
vous avez Henri Leclerc accompagné
beaucoup de mouvements sociaux vous êtes
battus pour les paysans les ouvriers les
mineurs les droits de travailleurs quel
serait aujourd'hui votre cheval de
bataille si vous aviez en choisir un
politiquement
l'écologie évidemment le climat
les conditions de la survie comment nos
enfants vont-ils pouvoir vivre c'est ça
qui aujourd'hui m'observer le plus mais
ça ne veut pas dire que j'ai baissé la
garde en ce qui concerne les droits de
l'homme donc vous rendriez la défense du
climat absolument moi je pense qu'il est
actuellement indispensable que il est un
effort considérable pour réfléchir à ce
que va être demain mais il ne peut pas
être concevable que aussi demain voit
une baisse en ce qui concerne la
reconnaissance des droits de l'homme
donc je pense que les deux sont
absolument indispensables et les le
souci des libertés va avec le souci
d'une vie possible et en même temps avec
une
vie possible et une vie socialement
possible enfin voilà merci